هالمره راح نتكلم عن اضطراب العاطفي
الموسمي اقتراب عاطفي موسمي يعني بس مو
بكل وقت بس بالموسم هذا الاضطراب الاكتئاب
اللي يحدث بسبب تغيرات الموسميه يطلع شتاء
يدخل صيف يحدث هذا يظهر في معظم الحالات
في نهايه الخريف بدايه الشتاء ويختفي في
الايام المشمسه خلال الربيع وكذلك هيك
احنا بنعرف ولكن مشاهدينا بعض الدراسات في
جامعه جورج تاون اكدت ان معدلات الاكتئاب
والقلق لدى البشر معرضه للارتفاع تخيلوا
بمجرد زياده الحراره درجه واحده فقط اكثر
من المعتاد فيما يعرف باسم هلا احفظوا هذا
الاسم الاكتئاب الصيفي سووا الدراسه
يلا وفق الدراسه الحراره تؤثر على الناقل
العصبي الذي يساهم في تنظيم حاله المزاج
للانسان بالف عل
تتمثل الاعراض في الارق تعكر المزاج ايضا
والقلق والذي قد يصل في بعض الاحيان الى
نوبات اكتئاب بينما يستعد العالم لمواجهه
موجات حراره جديده السؤال هنا كيف نحمي
صحتنا النفسيه من حراره الصيف الحارقه
الاجابه عند لميس تطلعنا على احدث
الدراسات التي تكشف العلاقه بين حراره
الصيف والصحه النفسيه وكذلك العقليه لدى
الانسان اعطينا الحل مستعدين لفصل الصيف
انا بصيبني اكتئاب بكل صيف احنا شهرين
الله يبعد الاكتئاب
عندما ننزعج نشعر بالحراره وعندما نغضب
الدم يغلي العلماء الان كشفوا عن التفاعل
المعقد بين الحراره الشديده ونتائج الصحه
العقليه السيئه مع ارتفاع درجات الحراره
ترتفع معدلات الانتحار والجريمه والعنف
فوفقا لدراسه اجرت بجامعه عام 2018 فان
الزياده في متوسط درجات الحراره بمقدار
درجه مئويه واحده في الولايات المتحده
والمكسيك ترتبط بزياده قدرها 1% في حالات
الانتحار اليات العلاقه بين الحراره
ووظائف المخ غير مفهومه جيدا ويمكن ارجاع
الكثير منها الى النوم الذي يصبح بعيد
المنال في موجه حار دون تكييف ومع مرور
الوقت يمكن ان تؤدي الاثار التراكميه لقله
النوم الى فقدان الذاكره وقله التركيز
وزياده التهيج تؤثر الحراره ايضا على
الناقل العصبي السيروتونين احد اهم منظمات
الحاله المزاجيه لدينا والذي يرتبط
ارتباطا وثيقا بمراقبه العدوانيه فهل
علينا ان نفكر في تغير المناخ باعتباره
ازمه صحه نفسيه سالنا الناس في السعوديه
عن طريقتهم الخاصه للتغلب على نفسها
السيئه المرتبطه مع ارتفاع درجات الحراره
في الصيف نتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
طبعا روح بحر هو احلى جو طبعا للبحر
ونحينا نكسب لون بشره وغيرنا نكسب فيتامين
دي طبعا بدون الشمس ما حنكسب فيتامين دي
انا بالاغلب من الواحد يشغله مكيف هنا
كمان احاول انه ما اطلع الشهاده كثير
بزياده
الاجواء المناطق الجنوبيه يعني زي ابها
الباحه الطائف ايس كريم وهوم واماكن مغلقه
يعني مكيفات اي شيء بارد تزلج بطريقه خاصه
بالنسبه لي من يوم من يوم ما عرفت الحق
اجلس في البيت ما اطلع
المكان لازم بارد
حلوه نفسيه حلوه هذا اول حاجه ثاني شيء
انه انا الاجواء خلاص معروفه اجواء الصيف
بالذات في جده بحر
[موسيقى]
دول بتختفي عنها الشمس تماما فبيزيد
الاكتئاب الا ان في 10% من الناس بيجي لهم
اكتئاب الريفيرس العكسي اللي هو بيجي في
الصيف لازم نبقى عارفين ههه لازم نبقى
عارفين ان في درجات من ده فيه السمر لوز
او اللي هي الحبات زي ما انت بتقولي كده
مش نوصله لمرحله الحزن والاكتئاب بس هي بس
انخفاض في المزاج في بعض الناس بتحس
بالعصبيه شويه التوتر لان هم لقوا ان درجه
الحراره لما بتزيد عن 20 بيبتدي يشعر
الناس بلا لما بتزيد درجه عن 20 بنبتدي
نشعر بعدم الارتياح لا لازم نعيش
لازم نعيش في القطب الشمالي احساس بسيط
بعدم الارتياح فكل ما زادت اكتر بقى ال 28
وبعدين 30 بيشعر الانسان
في الخمسين والعصبيه
هل هل هذا يبرر الى انه عصبيه مثلا سكان
هذه المناطق في الخليج وبعض المناطق في
الصحراء في المغرب العربي وغيرها من انه
الجو حار فيعكس مزاجيتهم وعصبيتهم يبرر
ذلك مش يبرر بس هي فكره انه لقوا ان الدول
القريبه من خط الاستواء اللي هو الصيف
بيبقى فيها غالب بيزيد الاشخاص اللي عندهم
الاكتئاب الصيفي ليه لان بيبقى نسبه
النهارده طويله ونسبه التعرض للشمس اكتر
ونسبه الحراره اعلى والرطوبه اعلى الحاجات
دي اللي هي الشبكيه بتاثر على بتمتص اشعه
الشمس تؤثر على الساعه البيولوجيه في
الجسم اللي هي السوبرا كاريزماتك اما صعبه
بتتاثر بيبتدي افرازات الهرمونات نفسه
يتلخبط الميلاتونين بيقل فبالتالي النوم
بيزيد وده بيعمل برضه اضطراب في المزاج
الكورتيزون بيعلى جدا وده هرمون القلق
والتوتر والاكتئاب وفي علاقه طرديه لما
بيزيد الكورتيزون بيقل السيرتونين اللي هو
الهرمون المسؤول عن اعتدال المزاج هرمون
السعاده طب شو بنقدر نعمل لحتى نحمي
انفسنا من السامر بلوز زي ما بتقولي يعني
انخفاض المزاج في الصيف ان الانسان يعمل
لنفسه روتين لازم الحياه الصيف ده دايما
شويه بيدي احساس بالانطلاق والخروج
فالواحد يعمل لنفسه روتين ثابت في البيت
لا يتجنب الخروج في وقت اوقات الذروه زي
الحر الشديد اللي هي الضهر في فتره الظهر
مثلا من الساعه خلينا نقول 11 للثلاثه
مثلا حاول ان نتجنب الخروج فيها يبقى
ندورز اكثر يبتدي ان هو برده يمارس الاكل
الصحي اللي هي الحبوب الكامله زي الشياسيه
الكنوا الحاجات دي جدا بتعلي المزاج
وبتزود انتاج التريبتوفين اللي هو النواه
الاساسيه في تكوين السيراتون الهرمون
المزاج الرياضه طبعا الرياضه شيء مهم جدا
والنوم ثمان ساعات من 6 ل 8 ساعات لازم
تنظيم ساعات النوم البحر مش في اوقات
الذره طبعا
والله يا دكتوره شكرا جزيلا لك ولكن
الواحد ما ينلام بدرجات يعني انت مجربه
الساعه الساعه 1:00 الظهر في يوليو في
منطقه الخليج تقريبا
الطب النفسي شكرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات